in this video we are going to use the
gdp equation that we have seen before to
think about how national savings relates
to investment and really it's a way to
algebraically manipulate things to
ensure that it fits with our intuition
so another way to think about gdp is
it's the same thing as national income
which we denote with a capital letter y
and gdp or national income we can
account for it by saying hey that's
going to be the sum of
consumption plus investment plus
government spending in a closed economy
we could also think about an open
economy where you have net exports right
over here let's just focus on a closed
economy for now so let me actually just
label this we're going to deal with a
closed closed economy in a future video
i will open the economy up
but how could we solve for savings
well what happens if we subtract
consumption and government spending from
both sides of this equation well then
you're going to have national income
minus consumption
minus government spending is equal to
investment
now what is another way of thinking
about this left-hand side of this
equation so the national level this is
the income
minus how much is being consumed and how
much the government is spending so it's
income minus the different types of
spending well you could view this as
national savings
national
savings
and we see here this identity that
national savings which is often denoted
with a capital s is equal to investment
and if that isn't intuitive for you at
first just think about it at a kind of a
human scale
if i am saving things and i am putting
it into a bank that bank will then lend
that money that can be used for
investment and we can break this down
even more if we want to think about
taxes
so let's just say t is equal to
taxes so let's just think about the
private economy first
so if we think about the national income
minus
consumption spending and then folks have
got to pay their taxes
so
minus taxes
and then where do those taxes go well
they go to the government so they stay
in the economy so notice i'm not
changing this equation i'm just
subtracting taxes and then adding taxes
and then i subtract from that government
spending
these two equations are equivalent and
this is going to be equal to
our investment in our closed economy
now if you look at this left hand side
right over here
you could view this as private savings
this is the national income minus how
much is being consumed minus how much is
being paid to the government so this is
private
private savings
and if you look at the second part
the taxes the government gets minus how
much the government spends this you
could view as public savings
public
savings
in most countries this is neutral to
negative so it's actually the public
savings are negative because the
government spends more than the amount
of revenue gets in taxes but either way
you could see that t minus g would be
the public savings and you add public
savings and private savings together you
get national savings